Transcriber: Alber Makhoul
المدقّق: Malakoot Barham
كيف حالكم.
هذا هو المكتب الخاص بي.
الأمر برمته بدأ عندما
اشترينا منزلاً جديدا.
اعتقدت أني سأصمم غرفتي الخاصة
بالشكل المناسب والمريح لي،
و لكن سعادتي لم تتحقق، لماذا؟
لأن والديّ عينوا مهندس تصميم.
مشكلتي مع مهندس التصميم بدأت عندما
قرر تصميم غرفتي أنا وفق ما يريده هو.
كل ما كنت أريده هو
أن يكون مكتبي أمام الشرفة،
من أجل أن يدخل النور والهواء
خلال فترة مذاكرتي.
على عكس المهندس الذي كان رأيه
أن موقعه بجانب السرير أفضل،
من أجل الاشياء التي تتعلق بالكهرباء
والقوابس وأمور المهندسين هذه.
المهم، بعد خلافات طويلة مع مهندس الديكور،
نفذ المهندس ما كان يريده
وأنا أصبحت مضطرة
أن أجلس على المكتب وأذاكر
وأنا لست بكامل تركيزي
وهذا الموضوع كان يدفعني للجنون
وأصبحت غير قادرة على الدراسة
ولا أستطيع التركيز
ثم بحثت ووجدت السبب لذلك
وهو شيء يدعى العمارة النفسية
ما هي العمارة النفسية؟ لو بحثت على غوغل
على معنى العمارة النفسية سترى هذا التعريف
العمارة نفسية هي التعاون
بين علماء النفس و المهندسين
في تصميم مبنى وتوفير الاحتياجات الخاصة
وتوفير الاحتياجات النفسية للمستخدمين
بشكل واضح أكثر.. هو أن تحضر
مهندس والأخصائي النفسي
وتجعلهم يعملون سويةً
من أجل أن توفر لك المكان المريح نفسياً.
ووجدت أربع نقاط مهمة جداً.
هذه الأربع نقاط هي سبب عدم راحتي في مكتبي.
النقطة الأولى هي: الإضائة
يمكن للإضائة أن تكون
العامل الأكثر أهمية بالتحكم بمزاجك
ما يعني هذا هو عندما تكون جالس بمكان
ذو إضائة طبيعية
ستكون مركز وسعيد وتشعر بأنك تتنتج أكثر
على عكس ما ستكونه بمكان ذو إضاءة سيئة
أو مكان ذو إضاءة صناعية
فالإضاءة غير الطبيعية ستسبب لك
الصداع والقلق وستقلل فترة عملك
من أجل فهم معيار الأضائة أكثر
أحضرت لكم مثال عن مكتبين
يبدوان مألوفين لكم أليس كذلك
إنها مكاتب مدرسية
أول مكتب هو مكتب بريستي كانسنن
والمكتب الثاني هو مكتب أبلكيتر
وهو مكتب (ب) هذان المكتبان
مختلفين جداً عن بعضهما من ناحية الإضاءة
لو نظرنا للمكتب (أ) سنرى
شباك صغير ولا يدخل إضاءة جيدة
فيجعل الشخص الجالس به
غير مركز أو مرتاح أو لا يرى جيداً
على عكس المكتب (ب) الذي يحتوي على إضاءة
جيدة ومريحة للعين وتساعد على التركيز
تجعل الشخص الجالس به سعيد ومركز أثناء عمله
وأيضاً بحثت...
ورأيت أن الطلاب الذين يذاكرون في إضاءة
طبيعية ترتفع درجاتهم بمقدار 25%
ولكن المكتب (أ) ليس سيئ لهذه الدرجة
إذا تكلمنا عن الألوان
فسيختلف الكلام كلياً، فالمكتب (أ)
يحتوي على ألوان مفعمة بالحياة
تحفز الأشخاص على العمل
وعلى الإنتاج أكثر.
وتزيد من إبداعه،
على عكس المكتب (ب)
الألوان به جيدة ولكنها باهتة
وتشعر الشخص الجالس بأنه ليس منتج
وكل شيء ممل أكثر
الألوان الجميلة تشعرك أن مساحة الغرفة أوسع
والألوان الغامقة تشعرك بأن الغرفة ضيقة
دائرة الألوان هذه تخبرك الاحساس الذي يقدمه
كل لون لك، نحن سنركز على لونين فقط
اللون الأول.. هو اللون الأحمر، والذي يجعلك
تشعر بالقلق، بالتوتر، بالحب أو بالشغف
على عكس اللون الأزرق الذي،
سيجعلك تشعر بالثقة بالنفس والراحة
والطمأنينة ولذلك لم يكن صدفة أبداً
أن تكون ألوان غرفتنا بالأحمر
حتى الكراسي بالأحمر.
وهذا من أجل جعل الطلاب
منتبهين أكثر أثناء الدرس.
ولكن قبل أن أقول النقطة الثالثة
يجب أن أعقد معكم إتفاقاً
الضجيج سيء ويجلب الصداع أليس كذلك؟
لو فرضنا أنك جالس تذاكر بمكان ما
وفجأةً رأيت شخص قادم بسيارة جديدة
وسعيد بها ومشغل أجهزة الصوت
وستشعر أنك تريد النزول وتحطم الأجهزة
فوق رأسه... وهذه هي النقطة الثالة
وهي: الأصوات المحيطة أو الضجيج
أثبت الضجيج أنه السبب
لقلق والتوتر والصداع المزمن
في دراسة أجريت عام2011
على الأشخاص الذين يقطنون قرب المطارات
رأو أنه عندما ازدادت ضجة المطارات
بقمة 10 ديسبل فقط وهي نسبة قليلة
الناس الساكنين بالقرب منهم
بدأوا بتناول أدوية القلق بزيادة 28%
هل تتخيلون ذلك؟
النقطة الرابعة هي: التهوية
التهوية الطبيعية أثبتت أنها مسبب لي الراحة
وزيادة بالتركيز والسعادة بالمجمل.
لذلك كل مرة تشعر بالحزن
تسمع عبارة “إذهب إلى البحر”
لماذا تذهب إلى البحر عندما تشعر بالانزعاج
لأن التهوية الطبيعية هي التي تشعرك بالراحة
عندما تكون جالس أمام البحر وتستنشق هوائه
وسائل التركيز لديك تزداد
وهذا ما يجعل من دماغك نشيط
ويعمل بشكل أذكى وأسرع
هل تعلمون من كان ماهر بموضوع التهوية؟
بالطبع الفراعنة، عبقرية الفراعنة بالتهوية
تظهر بوضوح في معبد “اثنى”
في جنوب “الاوصل” هذا المعبد يعتمد
على فتتحتين تهوية فقط
الفتحة الأولى قرب باب المقبرة
والفتحة الثانية بالقرب من..
باب غرفة التابوت أي باب المقبرة.
تلك الفتحتان صنعتا تيار الهواء عن طريق
فرق الضغط بينهما
والآن تبين لنا أربع نقاط،
التهوية والضجيج
الألوان والإضاءة. هؤلاء النقاط الأربعة
مهمون للغاية ويجب أن يتواجدو لديك بأي مكان
تقضي به وقت طويل، مثل
غرفتك ومدرستك أو حتى مكتبك
ولكن مع مرور الوقت
قل الاهتمام بالعمارة النفسية
وهذا ما أدى لجعل أماكن
جميلة جداً من الخارج
ولكن داخلها يسبب للأشخاص
القلق والتوتر وضيق التنفس.
وهذا أدى لإعلان
منظمة الصحة العالمية عن مرض جديد
يدعى: متلازمة مرض المباني
إذا ماذا يمكننا أن نفعل لكي نحمي أنفسنا
من هذا المرض أو ماذا نفعل لنوفر المحيط
الذي يعطينا الرضا النفسي
ويشعرنا بأننا مرتاحين داخله.
لن أقول لك أن تعود للمنزل وتغير كل تصميم
غرفتك لأن هذا شيء ليس واقعي
ولكن بأشياء بسيطة مثل، زراعة نبتة أو
أن تفتح شباك غرفتك
وهذا يؤدي على المدى الطويل
إلى تحسين حالتك النفسية
ويجعلك تشعر بالارتياح
في الغرفة التي تعيش بها
وإذا عدنا وتكلمنا عن المدى الطويل فعلينا
إعادة مفهوم العمارة النفسية من جديد
ويجب أن تكون مادة
أساسية في كلية الهندسة
لأنه لو كنت تستيقظ كل يوم من النوم
وتعلم أنك ذاهب إلى مكان تحبه
وتشعر بالراحة والسعادة به حقاً
ويساعدك على التركيز ويهتم
بصحتك النفسية، إنتاجيتك سترتفع.
وإنتاجيتنا كلنا كأفراد سترتفع
ولهذا السبب أريد أن يبقى مكتبي أمام الشرفة
شكراً
(تصفيق)